how do you think of an example in which
it is legitimate that you can merge the
two we're we're the the outcome is a
good substitute for the impact I am a
practitioner so I always look at it how
much would it cost and how much of
management time it would take to measure
because measurement of impact should not
substitute the creation of impact so I
would argue that in most of the cases
you should start maybe with simple key
performance indicators even if they mean
focusing on outcomes at the beginning
and then wherever it's possible and
doesn't take too much of management
attention you can go further and make
more deep analysis yes it's not perfect
but at least it will encourage people to
start evaluating impact and I find
impact evaluation is important not only
in understanding what your dollars are
doing but also in focusing the attention
of managers bait a social entrepreneur
or a fund manager to pursue those dual
objective and not only focus on
financial objectives because it's the
only one which is measured it's the only
one that you are accountable for I mean
if I could come in there complimenting
what what Julie is saying I think that
there are there are several problems in
this in this area one is that there has
been such complexity acquired so quickly
in the number of indicators that are
being measured the difficulty that it
actually takes physically on the ground
in Cambodia or El Salvador wherever it
might be to measure these these
indicators and additionally what's often
forgotten and I think implicit in what
Julie is saying is that there has to be
significant resource and time dedicated
on behalf of the investing company to
capture this data offer leaving aside
the whole self assessment debate in and
and and conundrum which takes time and
getting businesses to work and to grow
in these markets as often challenging in
opposite ears to burden them further by
asking for all sorts of qualitative and
quantitative data
these are companies that in some cases
might not even have basic financial
systems is an additional burden so we
have to question ourselves as the
practitioners how much pressure we're
putting on these businesses